this presentation is delivered by the
Stanford center for professional
development
today's speakers TV Iggy gave a very
nice talk a couple of years ago so when
we found out that he was doing something
new we said hey why don't you come back
and talk again especially since it
hadn't received a lot of exposure and
set before for some reason Microsoft so
this is the second talk outside in the
real world almost every large software
project involves multiple languages but
there's a lot of support for systems
that have lots of life at multiple
languages beyond same make and source
control drop aims to take a step beyond
that thank you Andy
and just as a process question we have
an hour so but right 5:30 ok it gives me
some time for questions ok hi everyone
thank you for coming and thanks for
having me here I'm gonna be talking
about what I do at work every day what
I've been doing for the last four years
it's a project that I sold and marketed
it it eventually became important you
know it's pretty fundamental to a lot of
the planning we do in developer
infrastructure so the tools that people
use to build software at Google uh it is
there's a lot of uncharted territory
here it's kind of evolving as we go I'm
going to tell you a little bit about the
motivations for the project and then
we're going to talk about the technology
talk about some of the future directions
and get your guys input so what I
noticed at Google and Amazon and
geoworks never else I've worked is
people like to write tools that process
source code for whatever custom reason
whether it's a syntax highlighter or a
linter or a transformer of some sort and
they're always reinventing the same
wheels they're like oh all right well I
gotta parse the code I'm gonna do a
quick and dirty parse of you know using
the easiest technology available which
is regular expressions and so if you
look at a lot of the the code processing
tools that are sort of generic
like lxr the linux cross-reference er
where you can run them on your code and
you know get some sort of index built
out of it you'll find that under the
covers very often they're using ray X
matching to try to parse source code and
as we all know that's not a very good
idea so some of the more sophisticated
tools use real parsers and they brag
about it and they say we use real
parsers to parse the code and that's
much better than regular expressions
well just to put it in perspective
here's the amount of work required to
understand source code and as you can
see these first two year scanning and
parsing are very very very small amount
of the overall work you once you have a
working parser for your code that gives
you the tree structure you you've got a
long way to go you've got a new name
resolution and type resolution and
semantics and data flow across module
etc etc it is lifetimes of work in fact
it's a lifetime of work per language so
the problem that I set out to solve was
make it so that you could get all this
and then build whatever tool you wanted
to build now what are some examples so
there's some broad categories I des are
a big one we all love our IDE right you
get your auto-completion and your jump
to definition and class browsing and all
that good stuff refactoring tools they
do a pretty good job of analyzing the
code they actually fall right about here
50 60 % of what we're setting out to do
and I'll talk about what the differences
are and where we try to exceed the IDE
bar the Eclipse bar the visual studio
bar so that's one category of clients
code browsing code navigation code
editing another category of clients is
static analysis so at Google we when I
started this project we weren't allowed
to be a static analysis project because
the company didn't think that it was a
core competency even though we hired all
these brilliant language and VM and
compiler people but after a couple of
incidents involving discovering
surprising dependencies that had crept
into our multi hundreds of millions of
Lyon codebase with ten to ten thousand
well-intentioned engineers hacking
for over a decade they discovered you
know we'd find things like the file
system depends on ads it was just wrong
and so you know they asked why why and
they realized they had no idea why
because they couldn't look at the code
and so they looked around and they said
this should really be a core competency
for us you you have a project that looks
like static analysis so we actually had
to go into our design document marketing
dock where it said grok is not a static
analysis project of line out not that's
a true story now of course we had to do
static analysis under the covers to get
at the information that we wanted a
surface but we had to pitch it as a
Productivity solution which to a large
extent it still is so I'm gonna and I'm
gonna show you a slide about some of the
some of the sort of categories of users
to help you understand who our audience
is here in a little bit but I have a few
disclaimer types life to get out of the
way first it's kind of necessary so
first of all what is this thing croc is
pretty vague there are different ways to
look at it one way to look at it is it
is it is a single canonical structured
index of all source code so in other
words you come up with a standard way to
represent artifacts about that code
syntax trees called your call graphs
type graphs will talk about all of them
and then you put it in sort of a
standardized representation you have
your you know your sort of logical
representation then you have physical
gratification zuv that representation
may be in a relational database or may
be in a graph store or whatever but the
general idea is well it's sort of like a
universal power plug right I mean why
can't we have a single universal power
adapter that powers all of our machines
instead of an apple one a Nokia one at
Samsung one this is basically that kind
of effort this is really best viewed as
a standardization effort also Emacs I
was accused recently if of manipulating
my agenda so that I could make Emacs
better and I said well yeah guilty as
charged because the idea is that I DES
were designed with the absolute best of
early 1980s software engineering
practice and and they're completely
monolithic Visual Studio you know
eclipse you know you name it these
things are they're designed with the
indexer to run in process
with your UI on your local desktop
everything else is moving to the cloud
everything so except I des and and
they're they're defiantly non cloud
they're like fat is good I've actually
heard them say this so you know the idea
is that we we we started this project
off by saying okay I E's are pretty good
indexers we're gonna start with that and
work our way up we're gonna just
basically saw eclipse in half and we're
gonna run the backend on server farms
and then serve it up to see what happens
but then it grew a lot and what we found
was that there are really three primary
surfaces that we're marrying together
we're providing sort of a hub-and-spoke
model because today eclipse is good at
Java and OK at C++ and kind of bad at
Python and JavaScript and really bad as
it goes down and the same thing goes for
Emacs Emacs is pretty good at C++ not so
good at Java it goes there and
everybody's got a long tail of languages
they do really half-ass support for okay
and the reason is that each one of them
has to redo all of that analysis right
the parsing the semantics analysis and
what until they just give up in
exhaustion and they can basically do
indentation at that point it turns out
that a lot of this analysis is very very
very heavily dependent on the build
system that you're using you really need
to feed in the dependencies and the
compiler flags and so on to the
compilers in order for them to do an
adequate job that turns out to be kind
of a hard problem but since this is all
about standardization it means that
ultimately we haven't done it yet we're
gonna have to standardize the way that
you specify dependencies and other build
metadata but once we're done
you reach this nice sort of ecosystem
that people can plug into and they
automatically get all the benefits
so if I have visuals slick edit you know
I like to look at it at or say if it's
pluggable then you can have it talk to
our service and decorate files with
metadata and do searches and whatever
else and you don't have to reanalyze all
the languages that's best the best the
aim and the goal was to actually put
peer pressure on compiler vendors ok who
have been operating a silos for you know
ever since we started writing compilers
right 5060 years and they
it's you know we assumed that they would
be sort of uncooperative until it became
clear that unless they were playing
along they would have lousy toolchain
support what actually happened was as
soon as they heard about it they said
sign us up what data do we have to admit
there has just never been a standard for
it before it's quite nice actually quite
gratifying we had to fend them off in
fact because we were ready yet all right
here's here's a big disclaimer slide
couple things get out of the way because
people are gonna be watching this video
and I don't want to sign up for a bunch
of false promises and so on so this is
not a search engine there are some very
good search engines out there Google
internally has a code search engine
that's quite good and hopefully someday
we can make that external but I don't
know of any plans for that now but you
can use you know free text search or
whatever you have to make this
distinction this important distinction
it's sort of like Google search versus
Wikipedia you go to Google search when
you're not quite sure what you're
looking for where it is you go to
Wikipedia when you know exactly what
you're looking for and you want to start
browsing edges on that information graph
okay so grok is a graph and once you
have an entry point to it we have all
the data you need superclass the
subclasses callers call graph we'll get
into it getting an entry point into the
graph is actually kind of non-trivial
today and we've had to team up with a
code search team and with the IDE teams
and so on to have common representations
of how to name a node and I'll talk more
about it but we don't do search and
we're not really a client per se we are
strictly a back-end service with some
some demo clients but we ultimately
expect expect this to to be you know a
marketplace where people contribute 20%
write open source type plug-ins for
editors and plug-ins for compilers and
things like that and there are a bunch
of similar projects one of them was
actually unfortunately called open grok
and when I started doing the search the
name search when I started this at
Google four and a half years ago Google
search engine didn't do stemming on the
word grok even though it's been around
since 1968 or 69 stranger in a strange
land and so I searched for open grah I
searched for grok and it didn't turn up
open grok
shame and it didn't do it again last
year when I looked so go figure
anyway open Drock is kind of a similar
product except that it uses a lot of
regular expressions and kind of you know
whatever matching but it is a product
it's a thing that you run and it gives
you search and it gives you browse and
it's if Drock is successful open grok
will be more successful by BL but I'll
use the analysis that we provide so
we're not trying to crush anybody with
this and it's you know making it
external is just a big complicated
problem we're talking about at the very
end but it's it's sort of a chicken and
egg problem so right now I'm just
talking about what we're doing inside of
Google but Drock is different from these
things in the sense that we do use real
compilers we made that we made that
decision right up front we're not going
to write any compilers it's a golden
rule okay because every compiler is a
lifetime of work it will suck you in and
you'll never come out again because it's
gonna be tons of fun and you know we can
optimize this or we can add that feature
or whatever you know and then you wind
up with GCC right or Perl or whatever
and or clang I mean those people they
disappear it's a vortex and we just all
we want to do is like cooperate them
without getting too close because there
really is kind of an event horizon if
Drock is successful ultimately will
become a scaling problem because
everybody will be contributing your
metadata to us but that'll become a
little bit clearer later and there have
been stin the past there have been some
attempts to do stuff like this including
by billionaire Charles Simeone from
Microsoft who did intentional
programming and his approach was we're
gonna have a structured representation
of the code and you're gonna like it
pretty much right you know and he spent
10 years and however many hundred
million dollars on it it was a failure
as we all know because of course
engineers aren't gonna like it they like
Emacs or whatever they've been using
right and so what we do is we try to you
know we try to embrace I mean will index
your code even if it's broken will you
find people checking stuff in in the
Google codebase people checking stuff in
with merge conflicts that are the arrows
are still in the file and once they look
you know what you know and whatever we
try to index it
we do our best so we don't judge your
sucky language that's one of our rules
trust me
languages don't well we're with we're
well with one's experience except maybe
see I mean like you get you get deep
enough into the details of any language
and the warts turn into you know tumors
it's it's they're all really really ugly
there's a lot of fun though to try to
figure out when they're the same when
they're sort of ugly in the same way
I'll give you some examples on a few
slides but I already talked about this
don't wreck impaler's sometimes we broke
in that rule okay we've written we've
contributed parsers we've contributed
you have to get the compilers like sort
of compliant and that's kind of an
effort it's a bootstrapping effort right
so we've we've contributed name
resolvers and pieces of compilers but we
really want as quickly as possible get
that into the compiler community for
that particular language so they own it
because language is evolved right
there's Java seven and Java eight and
C++ 11 and there's Python 3 and there's
equity script five and I mean every
single language is in the process of
upgrading you know it's its feature set
sometimes its syntax its grammars we
don't want to have to be in the position
of playing catch-up all the time week
you know we can't be in that business it
doesn't scale we ultimately want to
handle hundreds of languages and and
also the cross-product I'll talk about
that and it too and then you know
finally I mean we we've discovered that
a 90% solution is actually really really
useful in this space if you're getting
Auto completions and they're not 100% it
is there's no slide for this but I
should probably talk about it before I
forget we have run into a cultural
problem where we're different editor
communities have very different
expectations about what accuracy means
okay eclipse users are accustomed to
waiting potentially infinite amounts of
time but they get they get perfectly
accurate answers the unless you're using
reflection or you know dynamic loading
or whatever and they go well it doesn't
really count okay so they they've really
rationalized and compartmentalize this
away whatever anything that's statically
reachable by the by the indexer at the
time that you're getting your coffee
because it takes five minutes during the
auto completion is expected to be
accurate
whereas Emacs users their completion is
you open up 250 buffers and you use meta
slash to complete against all open
buffers and hope that one of them hits
right it works pretty well you know it's
kind of and so Emacs users if you say
well we can give you some pretty you
know pretty pretty much more accurate
information you know Auto completions
than you've got now they're like alright
so I'm yep
whereas Eclipse users say how could I
ever trust any of your data and and
unfortunately you know when it comes to
static analysis when they're running a
big MapReduce over the code and they're
saying I want to find all the cause of
this function and we miss one you know
they really freaked out so a lot of this
is kind of a UX marketing kind of a
trust issue where you know we really try
to get across the notion that you're
working with pretty good results here
and pretty good doesn't do it for you
you know go write your own because this
is actually it's actually surprisingly
grungy Google sort of core competency is
grungy datasets and I tell you our
source code everybody's source code is
there's a real mess so here's a really
high level super-high level look at what
our system looks like ok we have you
know source code including a lot of
handwritten source on a lot of generated
source yeah a lot of copy and pasted
source as it happens and we have a set
of you know dependencies like what is
the source files for your project what
are the libraries you depend on build
flags you know dash D Flags whatever we
send them all to our indexers the index
is run in parallel and a big batch job
every night and we write them into an
index and then we have an api service
but fronts the index and you can either
talk to the api service or you can go
against our index directly you go
against the index directly usually if
you're writing a MapReduce because you
don't want to make RPC calls for you
know a trillion operations ok we'll go
into more depth in a bit here's actually
a different way to look at it you can
look at rock as sort of a platform stack
so we have our dependencies below the
green line here somebody has to write
the code that's not us
somebody has to write compilers or
interpreters that are drought compliant
again hopefully not us the compilers
have to provide AP is in the ideal
scenario a grok indexer is just a
visitor the walks over their
intermediate representation so that
means the compiler has to run in a
special mode that the compiler is
probably not used to running in
compilers if you'll recall their job is
to yell at you if you made a mistake the
first time there's no point in the
compiler giving you 10,000 error
messages because you know forgot one
semicolon and so typically what
compilers do is they throw away
information that they don't need anymore
for example location information of you
know parse tree nodes and so on and they
they barf they give up at the first
error and they bunk and those are two
things we need to train the compilers
not to do because we want to be able to
index the code even if it's got a
mistake or it's broken or whatever
moreover we don't want them to generate
any code usually now ironically you have
to generate code to do name resolution
in Java Java this is this is the most
backwards
inverted upside-down logic you've ever
heard your life but C++ is far easier to
index than Java is okay now C++ is a
language is a real pain in the butt and
if you look at the internals of playing
it's got a very elaborate representation
for all the things that you can express
and C++ is a very powerful expressive
language but for C++ because of the way
they do header files every single one of
the symbol dependencies that you need is
expressed in your header file or the
compiler doesn't know what it is it's up
to the linker it's up to you know
somebody else downstream to figure out
where that thing is really defined which
means that all you need to analyze a
particular source file is it and the the
translation unit the transitive closure
the header files that includes and then
the command line flags and you're done
whereas with Java it may have to crack
open arbitrary directories full of jar
files class files go off and look in
that you know the constant pools and the
heads and class files to find names and
look them up and it has to check the
whole class path for this and to be very
slow and it's also lossy they don't
record all the information we need about
positions and stuff in the in the
third-party libraries so Java actually
turns out to be kind of a pain because
you have to you have to do some amount
of code generation just to
just to analyze it so and then the build
systems of course give you no API
what's the API to make well you write
your own parser for make files you know
it doesn't it doesn't have some sort of
programmatic interface that you can use
well maybe it does today I don't know
maybe can you make this anyway
at some point we feed all the analyzers
we stuff into a persistence layer and
then we either can do queries against it
we'll talk about those we have an API
service for like o of one lookups you
know that people do all the time for IDs
and then this is for interactive support
hopefully this will be a little bit
clearer after we look at the graph and
stuff okay this is interesting this is
important user tears we've identified
sort of this this pattern which is that
10000 engineers at Google use grok every
single day to jump to definitions of
symbols to do hover documentation really
simple stuff out file outlines call
graph browsing you know yeah I just find
it their way around I mean you jump into
a company with a hundred million lines
of code and you know no grep and you
need some help navigating around right
then you have sort of these power users
every team's got one right somebody who
writes scripts to automate workflows for
the team team has to do some sort of
hairy transformation because some other
team didn't provide the right API forum
or whatever and and so they write
scripts and so we have a grok
command-line tool for scripters where
they can make calls to our to our index
and get edges get nodes get you know
metadata file decorations whatever to
make it nice for scripters and then you
have analysts who want to do sequel
queries like we have we have a team at
google who is responsible for open
sourcing big hunks of our java code you
know the Google Java collections
libraries for example and so on and they
want to do things like find out what the
most popular api's are they want to find
out how people are using their code they
want to find out who's calling it and
from where so they they make extensive
use of our sequel interface we dump it
into a column i/o relational database
and they make extensive use of our
command-line tool and then you've got a
few people we're down to like 10 people
now this is an order magnitude shrinkage
but they have an order of magnitude more
leverage to enable productivity for
others and then we've got like the
very bottom level of people who are
doing massive code health refactorings
and cleanup Leonor code base and we know
them by name you know Tom and Kevin and
you know I mean it's like they're our
friends because they can do stuff that
makes life better for you know for
everybody at the company okay so a
couple quick quick screenshots that will
be completely illegible on the screen
but just to show that yeah we really do
have clients so we have this we have
this web client that was sort of a proof
of concept that we did that looks kind
of like a read-only Eclipse and you know
it's kind of useful as you can see it
has a search box
so I kinda lied about not having a
search engine but all it really does is
pretty much partial file name match so
you it's for looking up files and then
from there you can say oh I have you
know I have this node labeled statement
here I want to see who uses it and if
you actually click that show cross
references so you know here it says we
can just we can see the derived classes
and we can see the instantiation of this
class I clicked on a class called
labeled statement or we can jump to its
definition so I show cross references
and it gave me this so it's just like
lxr this is the simplest possible use
case for our index which is find me all
the places this thing was referenced so
that's kind of boring but you know you
got to do it and we have an Emacs client
does exactly the same thing so here it
is an Emacs when you open a file in
Emacs at Google it automatically goes
and makes an asynchronous call off to
our service to see if we know anything
about that file and if we do it'll
decorate the file with you know
underlines and error messages and
whatever other interesting stuff we
found here's a screenshot of the help
for our command line tool I was kind of
hard pressed to find any queries that
weren't big and ugly but we do have one
and it's growing and to basically what
amounts to a shell it's a shell for
basically browsing our index it's gonna
be kind of cool actually when it's it's
really evolved we also have sequel
queries this is a real sequel query
against our index against that class
that we were looking at just now it's a
JavaScript class
and as you can see what we've asked
asked for here is edge names so I'll
talk about nodes and edges on our graph
and how we represent source code and how
the challenges and trials of trying to
figure out whether final is the same as
Const stuff like that but in the mean
time you can see that you know this
class has these edges it has 138 methods
that are declared so it's kind of a lot
that it is a parser so it's probably a
bunch of recursive descent grammar
productions and it has some some usages
of the class maybe I better show you the
graph so that makes more sense here so
here's our graph our very small graph it
looks like this is kind of unreadable
but I'll talk you through it so this is
a very small snippet of source code it's
a hello world and C and then the
signature that the only function that we
actually call from hello world which is
printf okay
this generates a much bigger graph than
this this is a very tiny cross-section
what we find is that there's about a
hundred X expansion in terms of you know
file size to to metadata size you know
give or take and one reason is that we
have to we have to come up with nodes in
the graph for all the types so the
built-in types the composed type pointer
types parameterize types any sort of
type representation at all doesn't
matter how crazy it is right Haskell
Union types and you name it it's got to
be model in our system and another
another big set of sub graph of this is
that is the declarations of symbols
user-defined types or functions or
whatever we have references we create
notes for every reference so every time
you name something it has a node and we
have reference we have notes for files
pretty much anything that we would want
to represent in the index get to node
and it's relationships get edges and
it's bi-directional it's an unweighted
bi-directional graph every Edge has a
mirrored edge so if I return a Foo then
I can go to Foo and say who returns U
and follow the opposite direction edge
it's just quite useful sometimes so that
I mean that's the basic idea right you
start with a graph and then why that's
your big hammer and
everything looks like a nail and we'll
talk about what to do what we can do
with that graph in a bit here are the
things that we store in the graph we
store a simple table and a type graph
and a call graph and the build
dependency graph there's a lot of graphs
kind of overlaid in this thing file
system structure generated code we're
working on storing a STS I have a slide
about that ast s are pretty boring Hodge
sparse code get a tree mm-hmm
my compiler is prof. in college at the
University of Washington started off
with a statement that parsing was a
completely solved problem it was boring
and nobody was looking at anymore and
boy oh boy was he ever wrong we have
found some really interesting parsing
problems I mean when you get in the
multi language of course it gets pretty
crazy but even the representation of the
parsed code is everybody has a different
idea of what it means so we'll talk
about it
so here's what an actual node definitely
I mean this is this is the information
we store in our nodes you know I'm not
trying to hide it or anything well every
node has a globally unique identifier
globally unique ish yeah why is it ish
okay so we found a well for starters you
know like there are a lot of names that
I'm going to talk about this more in the
naming problem but well we find that
versions and sort of copies kind of
introduce hairiness into the whole model
like we have like two complete copies of
the java jdk sources for completely
different reasons in you know somewhere
you know in our depots and so if
somebody is making a reference to
java.lang object you could be either of
those or neither of those and generating
a unique identifier for them sort of
involves having to put more provenance
information in there like about which
which Depot it's in and so on so we keep
we keep thinking that it's unique and
and then somebody will pop up with an
edge case that that actually turns out
to be non unique so we've decided
recently basically that all nodes should
really be node sets that are usually
singleton sets but all clients should be
set up to expect an advanced that any
query that's really exacting and precise
could potentially give them back to
matches or more match
that are all like did you mean this and
we have a display name to show the user
what it looks like
we have display names for like local
variables like there's no syntax in a
language for anything that you can't
address you can't get the address of a
local variable if somebody's function or
a parameter right you know or a catch
block tag or something but we need to be
able to address it in grok because you
may be mean you need to be able to make
a link to it or you may just need to be
able to create a reference to it
temporarily when you're refactoring so
you can come back to it later and move
it and say oh yeah this thing is it
still there
so grok synthesizes names for everything
we make them up we have our own syntax
we found over time that that evolved
into a query language what happens is if
you have a method and it's overloaded on
parameters so like java.util.arrays dot
sort you know has like 80 overloads
because of the type explosion because
Java was well I'll languages Seth let's
put it that way but for a variety of
reasons they have lots and lots and lots
of overloads and so if you say I want to
go to java.util.arrays sort or I call
java.util.arrays sort potentially what
you're doing is a wild card match you
want to get all of them back like if
you're Auto completing say and so what
we have to do is introduce I mean you
know support for partial qualified names
and for and then for fully qualified
ones now in C++ the full qualification
for a particular name of like a template
instantiation can be pages and pages and
pages long we found signatures from
clang that were you know 64 K strings ok
it was astonishing you know it said it
looks like it looks like a mangled name
but no that's actually the declaration
that you would type in by hand for this
thing if you were you know fool enough
to have to do that so you know what we
try to do is come up with a predefined
name and this is this is kind of an open
area for us where we're really really
struggling with it but but basically we
recognize that there's kind of a
correspondence between name and URI and
we really want a sort of a restful view
of this whole index
and it's also kind of a query language
so I don't have a lot to tell you about
that today because we're still working
it out but it's definitely an
interesting problem the biggest and the
biggest thing to look at here really is
location this this is going to come back
and bite us again again slide after
slide location all code has to have a
location and most of it doesn't have a
location but we'll get to that oh yeah
here's a big one this node crisis
approval we have different node kinds
you don't have to read it all but
basically we represent all the things in
the code right kind of group roughly by
quatre there's tight nodes there's
function nodes there's you know number
nodes and we try to be so here's the
thing right is you can get really really
really precise for no reason at all cuz
nobody cares about the distinction they
just want to know it returned the number
they want to know it returns assigned in
but they don't care what the precision
is maybe right so grok has been a sort
of constant sort of evolution of
increasing precision right finer and
finer grained and modeling on demand so
we come up with a new client that says
well I need to know the difference
between electrical closure you know
that's writable and not writable and we
say oh well okay we go back and we fix
our model but we did see that there was
some value in coming up with an this is
an enum basically an enumeration of all
the possible roles that a node can have
it's it's its ears this is really
complicated but this works pretty well
and that's been our general goal is to
try to do something that's reasonable
for our users and then and then and then
iterate on it and here's what the edges
look like okay we went back and forth on
edges and we eventually wind up run with
this we wind up because every edge is an
arrow and you know you know the classic
problem where everybody draws their
inheritance arrows differently some
schools say I inherit from this class
and some people say I inherit from this
class right you know and that actually
matters like when you're composing a
syntax where people actually have to
type out an arrow in the query to say
what they're looking for so you know you
gotta you got to kind of canonicalize
these things and so what we came up with
those are the convention that the node
always extends from me to you right so I
extend you and I am extended by you
where I started you are extended by me
is actually that way at work so each one
of these is
by and large a verb and verb by it's not
always the case because we don't want to
have this incredible proliferation of
edges we like to reuse wherever possible
because we want to cross language which
I'll talk about in a little bit so we
have a couple of cases where we reuse
edges because they're kind of close
again we fuzz the semantics a bit and so
we wind up with for example base type
composing type and type parameter kind
of a triangle that we use sort of
liberally when we're doing parameterize
types
anyway the details aren't really
important just to know we have around
100 note kinds and around hundred edge
kinds and each new language that we add
adds how many new could note niche kinds
well if you were in fear and fewer and
fewer until eventually Sunday it's going
to be none now we have a we've met with
a lot of internal resistance to this
idea of having a cross language
representation for and part a part of it
is that compiler writers and actually
anybody who's like a really a salad or
an advocate of their language they feel
that their language is a special
snowflake and nobody else's could
possibly be as complicated or as
interesting as theirs they all think
this and you know we have not to date
ever found a feature that did not exist
in at least two languages now think
about that think about the craziest
language feature that you know most out
there you know the C preprocessor I mean
come on how many languages is that going
to be in well it turns out it's used
extensively in Mozilla JavaScript code
base hmm so you know there there is
nothing that you can you can you can say
is uniquely yours everybody has the same
you know like you know Lisp symbols you
know Ruby stole it so ruby has symbols
too you know I mean doesn't matter what
feature so yes Oprah come from haha so
we have that's kind of a rat hole we
there are a few cases where we know that
their language is coming where we're
only aware of one okay but it's almost
always possible for somebody to come
along and come up with a counter example
and say well you know that that's you
know that that's a list feature but it's
in Dylan or that's a small talk feature
but it's in squeak you know and
they can they can make a distinction
that you can say well those are really
kind of the same language and they say
no they're not in the defense who you're
talking to you because they may have
different runtimes or whatever so entry
Cal probably I'm at this point I'm so
jaded okay that probably even brain-fuck
has like a derivative right brainfuck
prime another guy that wrote that
language by the way okay so anyway in
any case what we do is we don't assume
anymore that a language feature is
unique but the big question that really
people want to know they say if they
think about this really hard and see
where we're going they say are you
writing the compiler am I going to be
able to write a compiler that goes
against your intermediate representation
and compiles code are you gonna have
gonna have that rich of a semantic
representation and if so how can it
possibly be language neutral because
those two are at odds because my
language is special and you know the
answer I think in the fullness of time
is that yes eventually you know there's
no reason why we wouldn't have that much
information and more we have all kinds
of stuff that we collect from linkers
and loaders and so on runtime even the
compilers don't have any access to it
all you might even be able to write a
better compiler against rir it does mean
that we are providing basically a union
or a superset operation over all these
language features and sometimes the you
know the the Unionists is one
okay come from maybe fine okay and so
we'll have one special lineage edge in
there just for that language but that's
not really the problem the problem is
conflicts the problem is when we've
modeled two things is the same and
they're not really the same so if we do
this is the last this is the last sort
of major sort of entity we have in our
draft we have nodes we have edges and
notes have modifiers modifiers are bits
of metadata that are composable right
you can you can basically or them
together they're flags and these really
are for this as a dumping ground this is
really become the dumping ground for
language semantics right we you know you
pretty much if you capture scope you
know in structure and you know the call
graph and the types of stuff at that
point this is just flavor right this is
just your particular language is curry
seasoning or MSG or whatever and so well
I'll go through some examples later but
there are subtle differences between a
lot of these things that look
initially the same and we argue
endlessly over whether they should be
the same for example Const final
immutable unmodified own modifiable and
read-only are they all the same okay
well we know the constant the same
because Const is actually basically a
wrapper type in C++ it's it's it's a
type that provides basically read-only
interface around the constant thing you
can cast it away by going around it so
cost is definitely out but the others
you know the semantics are weird I mean
if you think back to what javis final
means first of all it means two things
and so one one one decision that we made
early on was whenever a language has a
keyword or a modifier that means two
things we're gonna split it into two
modifiers so final means you you can't
subclass it or you can't override it it
actually means three things depending on
whether it's on a class or a method or
if it's on a variable it means you can't
write it once it's been initialized so
we split those into you know non so
class of all and I don't have to look
here now I'm curious terminal I think is
what we eventually called classes that
you can't subclass and we have immutable
for things that are that are right only
but in Java you know there's this really
subtle language edge case where if you
have a final variable and I compile
against it it's a constant safe you know
static final a to X equals foo and I
compile against it then what I get is a
copy of fool so even if they did change
it say through you know runtime
reflection or whatever or they just
changed it recompile it and I didn't
recompile now we're talking about two
different copies of foo that's a
subtlety that matters to compilers it
matters to run time and we don't capture
it at all
in our view currently of you know we
just say yeah you can't write it you see
so you know each one of these things we
we wind up having to go through all the
languages we know so I hired a bunch of
people who know a lot of languages and
you know and we refine it as needed but
we try not to get too refined because if
you over model it then it's just wasted
where if you're never going to have a
client who
hares in fact you can do some damage by
saying okay well we have instant floats
and big knobs and complexes and and
they're just like I just want to know if
it's a number and so basically you have
the clients now having to back into ad
hoc polymorphism over you all of your
finely modeled types because what they
really want is when it behaves like a
thing so anyway public global default
exported they all mean kind of different
things built in extra and pre declared
implicit auto-generated all kind of the
same all mean different things etc so
what we do is you know we do our best we
we make them to say we split them out
when we need to
okay let's talk cross language cross
language how do I adjust call each other
does anybody ever write in one language
of course not never ever not for
anything significant so you can call via
foreign function interface is Python
calling the C++ say you can call through
our pcs obviously you know Java calling
a Python server say you can embedded
languages World of Warcraft Lua you know
you write all your scripts and it's
calling down into C language of betting
also you know probably the canonical use
case if you're not in the world of
warcraft would be javascript and
browsers also pretty big and they have
the Ekman if you look at javascript it's
a true scripting language not like Perl
or Python or Ruby where they it's just a
dynamic language that tried to be
everything for everybody know that
javascript is a scripting language in
the sense that they've clearly defined a
an interface by which it's expected to
talk to an underlying runtime and
basically allow you to compose and call
the entities like for example your DOM
and your CSS representation and your
browser frame windows and so on right so
you know we want to be able to trace
from a JavaScript call down into the Dom
or from a JavaScript call over Ajax do
you drive a server I mean of course we
do everybody wants that IDs don't do it
today but there's absolutely no reason
we couldn't figure that out if it's you
know at all statically decidable or if
we can even cheat I'll get to the
cheating slide in a bit and of course
yeah there's there's code cojan is huge
my god everybody uses so much code Jen
especially Java people but everybody but
especially Java people they use a lot of
code generation because Java is
fundamentally incapable of expressing
you know a whole bunch of things that
other languages have no problem at all
with and so Java people like to write
declare things in XML or and whatever
and then compile it down to JavaScript
rants formers are even peskier than
compilers compilers sometimes will
record position information for you from
where stuff came from so you can you can
jump back to it right transformers are
usually somebody's hack right somebody
wrote a hack oh yeah we're gonna make
JSON out of this and so uh so it's a
perl script and and you know then they
left the company and it's been running
like that for years and you know you're
like hey we want to update your perl
script to get grok metadata information
and it's it's pretty hard it's pretty
can be pretty hard code generation is a
big problem for us but we're doing
pretty good job with it I would say
anyway the overall the overall point
here is that there's a gazillion ways
that languages can talk to each other
and it would be kind of foolish for us
to try to train our indexer about all of
them like hardwiring it it would be
better if we had sort of a clearinghouse
for saying ok here's a way and it's
tricky problem okay if I okay so let's
take a mozilla rhino it's a JavaScript
implementation on the java vm it's used
in Google Apps Script it's used in all
kinds of applications it's JavaScript a
server-side JavaScript that runs on the
Java VM it compiles down to Java
bytecode you can make any Java call from
job from JavaScript syntax basically but
it has a JavaScript you know runtime
there too and you know you want to you
want to call into you know a Java Bean
or something let's say actually Rhino is
is powerful enough to let you declare
Java classes Jai thawne can do this too
you can actually create a class that can
be called from Java okay and so now
what's happening is you're introducing a
cross language binding the the job be
the thing that's analyzing the
JavaScript of that Python side has to
say okay I'm introducing a binding over
on the Java side so you know how do you
work what's your guys is naming
convention for that because they're
completely different
across languages so we have to solve
this problem of basically allowing
languages to sort of inject information
into each other and it's something that
we are we made sort of significant
progress on but it is it is distinctly
non-trivial so the next like five or six
slides are just going to be problem
after problem after problem we've run
into you and it's just a big been kind
of a miserable slog and the only thing
that keeps us going really is that our
customers love it now they express their
love by saying your index Sox it's
driving us nuts then they say like why
is this template expansion not taking me
to the right place or right but it's
tough love but we know they love it
because they're using it right so
default okay so the location problem
okay you want to jump to the definition
of something you want to see it as a
cross reference right somebody's calling
you how do you show it if it has no
location that includes things like
default constructors
you know implicit you know items that
are generated anything a macro expansion
you know JavaScript when you write
function foo and JavaScript actually
three things are created right your
function the function constructor object
which is also a function and the
function prototype object which I
believe is also a function although I
don't think they get their own
prototypes and constructors I'll have to
reread this back but any case at least
three things are created at that
declaration site so today what we do is
we say yeah well yeah it's it's kind of
there I know you didn't really say
there's a prototype here you could have
said it but you didn't so right now we
use some sort of hacks and there are
certain situations where there's a
reference to a file but not to a
particular location in a file classic
example an import I'm importing this
file you know in Python or whatever so
where's the location of that well it's
kind of the whole file sorta and so
we've kind of had to work out these
conventions where you know there are
different kinds of locations some
locations are a span starts here ends
here some locations are a whole file
some are like a nothing right it's like
right here between these two characters
some locations are what's the location
of void in C okay well the location
we've decided is the canonical
documentation on whatever website we
trust the most so the location is a URI
we do that for all the built-ins and
then then we have languages that have
operator overloading we'll let you
overload the array bracketing operator
and then when you actually use it what's
the location of the reference is it the
first bracket or is it the last bracket
is it the whole thing or do you just
shoot yourself and because it's a lot
easier so it's the first bracket I don't
know we just made something up so this
is kind of hard but we need to generate
locations for things I mean yeah when
you get into electrical closures you
know there's kind of a pseudo there's a
scope there we know it's there the
location is its runtime thing right but
we need static locations for everything
so location big problem and what we do
is we make them up naming you need to be
able to name stuff right like anonymous
functions which by definition have no
name and yet we have to name them and so
what we do is we need I want a dollar
two and whatever right you know we give
them names local variables don't have
names that are visible to the rest of
your program but we invent our own
little syntax so it's food out bar and
purse and some local variable right
eventually we need to be able to name
AST constructs like try and catch and
switch blocks and because well because
people need to be able to query on that
stuff imagine if you will she looked
skeptical which is why I'm clarifying
here
imagine legal needs to do a query to
find out anytime somebody called a
function with the word Mozilla in it in
a loop but that's that's the thing they
need to know if somebody called anything
with Mozilla in it in a loop you don't
care what language it is you don't care
what the destination was it just had the
string Mozilla and ahead of you know
some sort of loop okay well that's
that's a pretty language neutral query
at that point right you need to be able
to have some way to say in a loop in the
query and so being able to name st
structures and we're not the first to do
this we've seen a lot of cases where
people have come up with sort of ad hoc
tree pattern matching your pattern query
languages for a sts and they're all
useful you know on their own way
except when you had the preprocessor in
and then they're completely not useful
but it's a complicated problem anyway we
make up names for stuff we have to come
up with names across languages so here's
a big one right is everybody is always
calling they're always calling or using
an identifier in some other language
that somebody else is going to figure
out but they're talking about in a dot
comment and they're like okay what's
gonna happen here is there's going to be
a code generator and it's going to
generate the study h-file and then
that's going to get linked into this
program so see and there's no way to
link to it because there's no such thing
as cross-language linking Javadoc lets
you link inside a java doxygen lets you
link inside a c++ right hi doc j s doc
every single language thinks of itself
is the only language in the world
they're like professors right and so you
know they're like yeah nobody else
matters it cuz except my class well we
have to do is we have to come across we
have to say all right well basically
grot colon slash slash right come up
with a URI syntax that all languages can
share we're not there yet but we're
getting there the aliasing problem yeah
so the aliasing problem is you have a
name that really is a reference to some
other name C++ reference parameters
Python import food as bar so I imported
through but I renamed it and that's kind
of a problem right because like if
somebody says well I want to find every
place where somebody used foo you have
to include all the bars too so what you
could do is you could just say oh yeah
that's the same thing and not not
capture the fact that there's an alias
there which works until somebody says I
want to find out everybody everywhere
somebody used an alias of foo and then
they're like oh you can't throw any
information away if they potentially
need that so so you actually have to
have a note bar in a node foo and you
have to have two things you have to have
an edge between them that says oh yes
there's an alias here and you have to
automatically flatten or join those when
people are doing the query where they
don't want to distinguish the two right
and so in other words your single edge
lookup all of one really guaranteed it's
going to come back in three milliseconds
no matter rain or shine now a sudden is
an arbitrary walk of declarations and
decals and and aliases and whatever and
it's in its hairy uh well we got to do
it
we're like the post office we got to
deliver
the syntax tree problem okay yeah ast is
easy right easy no so when you we found
early on that everybody was using the
word AST or syntax tree or parse tree or
whatever and they all meant different
things it's like they're walking around
they had these little thought bubbles
and they all had completely different
scribbles and the bubbles some people
meant they just wanted a tree like these
guys were doing this this binary tree
diff algorithm on code reviews where
they were trying to narrow down the part
of your fire where you had broken
somebody's build and all they needed was
a tree structured representation they
didn't care about the language of the
names or anything they just wanted to be
able to like do basically binary
division on code double code blocks they
really wanted to treat their most other
groups come along and they say well what
good's a tree if I can't look up the
name and the type of the name and the
symbol table and you know the type table
right so they want you know basically a
full intermediate representation a
decorated tree an annotated tree that's
gone through maybe semantic analysis and
tells you whether there are error nodes
in there right variables that have been
used before they're assigned you know
definitely or whatever and then you get
like compilers will lower the tree as
they go right they start off with some
source I'm gonna make a tree but they'll
be like ah you know other things
eventually gonna turn into a job so I'm
not even gonna represent it as a loop
I'm just gonna create a jump label and
generate the partial byte code for that
thing right right now okay which screws
us right because now we've lost we don't
know we know our faithful representation
of the original source code so we one of
the reasons that we go in and we
contribute parsers is we have to go and
we have to add a separate code path for
toolchain mode that doesn't do any of
that no no stuff like pre lowering which
messes up the performance like it's
lose-lose because now we have to we are
there have two separate parsers which is
a maintenance problem or we have two
separate code paths which is still
potentially a performance problem and a
source of bugs or we have one code path
that has a lot of ifs in it we haven't
you know we haven't come up with a good
solution for this but and yet tools are
so important I mean why did I do this
project I did this project really
because engineers smart engineers a lot
of engineers from Stanford came because
they just go next door to Google we're
coming in and they were making language
decisions not based on the merits of the
language
but as it turns out on the merits of the
tool chain and that turns out to be sort
of the status quo Engineers make their
from their default choices about you
know what they're gonna be comfortable
doing something and based on the quality
of the tools and the type of tools that
they used to using and then well that's
kind of stupid what if you know what if
this language is way better than that
language for this particular task and
the answer was they don't care and so if
we could find a way to make you know
sort of saying the universal high
quality tool support for all these
languages then in theory okay some
engineers might try to use a different
language hopefully I mean it's not
really that hard at that point I mean
the biggest argument against bringing a
new language into a company they say oh
well it's scary what if somebody looked
at something you couldn't figure out
what it did well you know at first I was
like well you're stupid and then you
know you know over the years I tempered
that to be I see this is a tools problem
okay you shouldn't have to figure out
what it does it should tell you what it
does which i think is a bit more
moderate see so you know my old age I'm
getting a little bit less grumpy now I
get mad at the languages themselves
because I'm like why aren't you telling
me what you're doing okay so then we
have where we oh yeah do you include
comments in a syntax tree no because
they're not part of the syntax they get
stripped out before the parser even sees
it right except everybody needs it what
if Yuri fact what if you're using the
syntax tree for refactoring and you want
to move something around you want to
carry the comments in that locale with
it right in the vicinity
you know same thing with keywords nobody
ever stores keywords like well restore
keyword nodes with a location and a span
and you know all this metadata about it
when it's a keyword and the answer is
well same thing right refactoring code
navigation code understanding so we wind
up having to store a lot more
information it's a huge pain in the butt
mix language becomes an even huger pain
I have some really clever stuff I can't
talk about in this space
sadly my team's not letting me but maybe
I'll come back in a year and I'll be
able to talk about that next language is
gonna get really interesting okay the
opacity problem yeah this one's cool so
what I noticed as I was writing these
analyzers is it frequently there would
be information available you right there
and it's like am I allowed to use that
like for example you know somebody's
making a query inside of a string and I
know
statically like the system is Aquarian
right you know they're passing a JD
passing a sequel query into a through a
JDBC API say write or or they are
they're importing something but the
language syntax dictates that you put
the import inside of a string and so the
parser go does this right so the parser
comes will actually C++ you can use a
string or a literal right you know a
symbol so you know sometimes the partial
will give you back and say oh yes this
is a string yeah you know the move along
now right
and we're like but wait right we know
the context here we could be actually
going in there and figuring out what's
in that string or what does it mean what
if it's a regular expression literal
it's like well you know we have access
to maybe to the Reg expresser it has its
own tree representation what if we could
give the user the ability to navigate
inside the rag axe okay for red x's that
could actually be pretty useful for some
pretty hairy ones right so we find all
these situations where we can actually
look at data that is it's inherently
noisy if messy right there may be
malformed it may be incomplete it may
not be there in all source files and yet
another another good places comments
should you here's its basic question as
a it's a UI question should your editor
underline a name of an identifier in a
comment okay so I've got a class foo bar
Baz you know and I'm using foo bar Baz
all over the place on my code and I
mentioned foo bar Baz in a comment and I
hover over it should I be able to see or
is the comet private you not I mean is
it opaque is it quoted so I shouldn't be
looking in there and the thing is if you
try to do what I think is the right
thing and actually underlined the name
then you start getting into heuristic
land because what if the identifier is
there th e re right and they say oh well
hello there and they're not really
talking about there but you underlined
it you know it's like those horrible ad
schemes that just look for just random
you know text matches and they they you
know you're you're reading an article
and they're saying oh you're looking for
though here it's click on this right
that's horrible right it's a horrible
experience and so you know your
heuristics start to get kind of fancy
about what counts as a as a potentially
resolvable name inside of a comment but
we do it in people love it
my except when it's not they say hate
you but it's love
okay the linking problem oh yeah the
linking problem we use real compilers we
brag
we thought we were so cool turns out
compiler sock right compilers punch on
everything
compilers only care about compiling a
particular translation unit one class
file Wan dot a file a dot o file right I
mean you know their their jaw or one
byte code snippet and and and compilers
are critically dependent on the inputs
like the preprocessor and and and more
importantly you know later phases like
the linker and the loader and and those
things do a lot of the name resolution
where the compiler is just like punt
right and so we ask the compiler so what
is this thing and I was like mmm mmm
that's the official answer from you know
the client team or whatever so then we
got to go to the Laker team say he huh
we need to make your linker drop
compliant right yeah they're like oh
yeah I know we can do a good job with
that except for all yeah this is a DLL
you're gonna go have to ask the runtime
for that ah it just goes on forever
right people like defer stuff lazily and
so you know this is a problem Drock has
to play the role of preprocessor and
compiler and linker and loader and I
mean at some point I mean this is
metrics we're giving people metrics on
their code and metrics beget metrics you
got me on my metrics ran everybody
nobody can look at a metric or a graph
or a chart without wanting more right oh
that's interesting why why right in the
making go back to the drawing board
it doesn't matter until you can watch
ants walking around on the loading docks
right you know they're like well where
did that come from so the thing is like
we're gonna run in this situation people
are like well you do a really good job
with static analysis but if you looked
at the log data anywhere like yeah yeah
yeah yeah we'll get there
so Drock really has to be I mean really
has to understand everything about the
code that's available eventually look oh
we're almost in the last slide it's good
because they have time for questions so
analysis of queries I finished this
slide like right before so we're
starting to do queries like real for
real queries right not just lookups but
you know analysis now you can get people
the index and we could say go ride a map
or do this and go wild and figure out
whatever you want about the code which
is just like a restaurant saying here's
a cow and a knife on a plate you know go
make your own steak right it's no fun no
buddy's gonna do it
messy and and so what we want to do is
we want to try to find a sweet spot you
have to use a new metaphor because I
think I just killed her without one so
we're gonna have to find the sweet spot
where you know casual users who don't
want to learn a bunch of stuff can do
reasonably rich and sophisticated
queries on the code and they come to us
all the time with these queries I mean
every single day somebody's mailing me
and going hey Steve you know what's the
syntax for saying okay I want to find
all the methods the return
httpservletrequest and I go oh yeah
that's easy that's just a single edge
yeah that's one look up and they go
already subclass of HTTP requests I'm
like okay because that's a graph walk
that's a graph expansion
well we found okay first off we started
kind of cloning the clips and lxr and
some of these you know older tools and
we would do cross references and I
showed you cross-reference to say so yes
and run those cross references right
what we found is the cross references
are AK and predefined query of sort of
generic blandness that's kind of
minimally minimally appealing to
everybody but not very satisfying to
anybody and what people always want to
do is they want to add filters they want
to say well yeah I want to see all these
results but only for my project only for
their project right or only for files
that end and you know foo and and then
they want to watch so so and then they
want to take that set of nodes and they
want to they want to follow an edge and
then probably our filters and follow
another edge and they basically are
doing this this expand contract lather
rinse repeat
it's XPath basically right that's
exactly what XPath does for xml
documents right you select a note state
you have a moving cursor as it
interprets your query your XPath query
it's keeping track of the current node
set and it gives you not one not two but
13 different dimensions that you can go
on from that node you can say follow the
ancestors all my siblings on my next
siblings my descendants my children my
namespaces my attributes whatever it's a
horrible horrible mess right well when
we looked at ours we have like a hundred
different dimensions so you could
potentially want to go in its all the
edges that we have right I showed you
the list earlier so it's actually
essentially quite a bit more complicated
than XPath the thing is we're looking
for a sweet spot here
we don't want to manual this thick I
want something that is roughly as you
know as hard to learn or as easy to
learn as regular expressions or XPath
tool that everybody can learn once get
out the manual if they have to do
something really fancy but for basic
queries it's pretty easy right and I
want it to go and do the and I don't
want it to be able to answer every
question in the world but I want us to
be able to do some reasonably rich
queries because people need it people
need it so you know I have no idea how
to do it I really have no idea I mean
we're just starting on this we do have
we do know how to interpret it we know
that Google has some really really nifty
graph computation engines that we can
shove our graph into and they can tell
us spanning trees and cliques and
clustering and and all kinds of cool
stuff so this is all you know uncharted
territory obviously you can use data log
and sequel and whatever we do a sequel
today
the problem with sequel is it can't
really you can't express recursive joins
and that's what people are really doing
with this graph walk they're saying okay
joining all that to this and run all of
it to this and then filter select where
select where and since you can't do
recursive join a sequel your only option
if you want to offer people to reduce
the number of joins necessary for a
given query is to denormalize which
Google does a lot of Google's like what
full table scan why do a full table scan
when you can look at every single row in
parallel at the same time right so at
our you know our Dremel sequel index
works or they'll say you know uh-huh
why walk the edges when you can just
store the transitive closure that blows
up really fast but if you narrow it to
the really common queries and so let's
say take four take an example I want my
superclass chain multiple inheritance
that means potentially it's a big dag
that goes up right so you could have
them walk potentially you know 10 12 15
however deep your class hierarchy is
levels to fetch that data or you could
just from every class store a link
called ancestor to everybody in its dag
of its superclass chain its ancestor
chain it's wasteful its piggish it's
expensive it's horrible right but it's
awfully convenient we need that sequel
query and just go give the ancestors
right so you know it's always as usual a
space-time trade-off
that's where we're at today so a little
scaling yeah we've got kind of a scaling
issue I think I suspect the Google's
code base is nowhere near as big as
Microsoft's or Amazon's but we do have
10,000 village into engineers cranking
out code and everybody measures the code
based size every once in a while and
they all come over radically different
numbers I mean these numbers are I mean
I might as well just be making them up I
mean it's really weird you would think
especially since we have a single tree
more or less that you could just look at
it and see how much code is in there but
on any given day it'll it'll vary just
dramatically and people like what why
are there 20,000 fewer JavaScript files
today nobody knows we really don't I
mean it would take forever to go figure
it out you figure it out and go oh and
and then they wasn't worth the time
right so so you know it's kind of a
mystery at this point I'd love to turn
grok into a metrics package that can
tell people all about how big and hairy
our code base is there right now
basically it's more of our enemy than
our friend right we have to run
analyzers over all of our code all day
long and what's more users not happy
with yesterday's data they want to know
the data that's up to date with their
typing you just added a function you
want it you know you want to be able to
find all the colors of that function you
just wrote and so we need to be able to
write you know we need to sort
interactive which we're working on
there's a you know some tricky problems
with mixing your local data with a
global data right if you delete a
function we can't just go oh okay well I
don't see it here so we'll go look in
the global index because you deleted it
we actually have to put in a deletion
token right all the standard stuff it's
actually turned into a garbage
collection problem you look at it
closely enough when you look at
incremental indexing over time so but
that's the ball because we want to
actually store all the revision history
for all the code every time somebody
doesn't change any change we want to
just basically layer it on to the graph
with versions and then you can do
historical queries and people will love
it except when it doesn't work in the
mojitos but that's tough love and then
we have all these other challenges a big
long list a big long list other Depot's
other languages other build systems
other clients incremental indexing
interactive canonicalizing AST s so that
you know they can be the same across
languages except when they can't be
standardizing all these protocols etc
etc it goes on forever
this project will take forever so you
know what do we do well we try to you
know use other people's work as much as
possible now a lot of people have come
to us and said how can I help and the
answer is well we're not actually like
pushing most of the stuff out
open-source yet because it's kind of not
ready we're embarrassed to show it it's
buggy if I don't know if our own
engineers are complaining about it we'd
hardly want the whole world complaining
about it however you can prep pee-yew
and anybody watching this video and
anybody interested in this space at all
can prep by going in we can even publish
a doc about this we have an internal
document that says what a compiler has
to spit out to be kraut compliant
because it doesn't matter if your
formats exactly the same as ours right
we could write a visitor that walks it
it gets the info we need as long as
you're providing it and so you know if
you happen to be working with a language
community or compiler or an interpreter
or a code generator or transformer or
anything that spits out code or
processes code and spits out you know
stuff then you should probably take a
look at the document that I'm no doubt
going to have to publish that says you
know here's what we look for it's pretty
basic we want an ast that represents the
code with location information for
everything and we want a symbol table
and we want to be able to look up types
and if you're calling it at some third
party package we're all gonna get all
the information for that thing - right
and don't throw anything away
expose it all it's not too hard you can
contribute to open source
you know compilers you can you can write
your own type inference err we do
dynamic languages - we have a great type
for instance inference for JavaScript
we're working on a great type inference
surfer Python they do outstanding jobs
it's almost as if you're writing Java
code or C++ code you can hardly tell it
as a dynamic language you know go in and
do it for Ruby so that'll be easy for us
to grok Ruby you know or Lisp or or
whatever or if you're in the editor
space for in the tool chain space if you
use vim or Emacs or eclipse or IntelliJ
or any extensible editor you know go in
there and and and you know if you ever
get to get an urge work with them to
split it up and modularize it so that we
can be the index so that they can be a
thin client that does a nice
presentation of the index but that
doesn't need to do the analysis we do
the cloud all right that's it questions
talk y'all out yes
would you look at searching how the code
is used like if someone searches for a
loop would you return instances and tail
recursion ah yeah so uh we would
actually yeah so we that that would have
to be language specific right if it were
skiing or if it will say closer we would
have to actually specify to the youth we
would we would model taro tail-recursive
contracts differently from loops even
though the compiler is just going to
compile it down to a loop right so now
now that said okay this is that's
specifically for the use cases we have
today but we've heard a lot of customers
come in and say well we want to do
security analysis using your
representation which implies that we
need to a store you know the data flow
graphs and control flow graphs and so on
right so which means single assignment
basic block representation where it
really is just a loop right it's just a
jump target and so you know down at that
level they really don't care whether
it's tail call optimization you know or
it's a loop or what right go to you know
they don't care so a lot of it depends
on the client whether they need to know
or not other questions yes did you
finally good use covered law students at
Google yeah did I personally finally get
to use common lisp inside Google no not
yet
we we did purchase ITA which is a
fantastic flight reservation system that
was written largely in Common Lisp and
so it has become a semi quasi blessed
language in Google as long as you don't
use it it's complicated politics are
always complicated but uh you know
there's sort of support for it you can
you can you can actually use it to talk
to Google infrastructure now whether you
have the guts to use it and not get
death threats from your you know
colleagues well you know I got a death
threat for using Scala at one point it
was a half joking death threat so it was
like half a death you know at that point
I was like I don't think I'm going to
use it down the road I hope so and the
way that we're gonna do it is we're
gonna write a grok analyzer for Lisp
that makes the tools just as good as
they are for for Java today which is a
really painful thing to say for anybody
who's got a lisp background
because there was a day when Lisp had
the best tools and small talk it will
come again any other questions yes you
should want to stop with with static
analysis have you okay yes so we've
talked a lot about static analysis we
thought about doing any more dynamic
analysis and the answer is yeah about as
much as that I mean we have some people
who are who are doing different kinds of
dynamic analysis obviously we've got
some JIT teams some some vm teams been
hearing you know JIT tracing and that
kind of thing we haven't really talked
to him much yet we've really got to kind
of nail the static side of it first it
would be kind of an I don't know I mean
there are a lot of different directions
that we can go we can go off and chase
them and for a while we did because we
were looking for low-hanging fruit you
know easy victories but then eventually
we realized that we had this giant
sparse feature matrix and what we really
needed to do now that people were using
it was really fill in some of those
those sub matrices so that people would
trust us and I would rather get nailed
the trust on the static before we do
dynamic than do a half-assed job at both
Sunday questions yes there's another you
had compiler plaques on your list
there's another whole space out there
like what version of the compiler is
doing this yeah what is this package
running on yeah so the question is you
know I said oh yeah compiler flags as if
I there's only one compiler for the
language or in one operating system is
the target when in reality there are
multiple compile especially for C++
right you know there's multiple
compilers there's multiple multiple
systems that's has system header files
you could be bringing in yeah I mean you
know analyzing windows code is actually
a little bit different from analyzing
Mac code or Linux code you know and this
actually shows up in the ast
representation thing right because
different compilers have different ast s
for everything right I mean the way they
represent a method it might be
completely different you know often
compilers will translate them down into
a child child sibling relationship tree
you know so they can quickly just
iterate over the tree but if they do
rich any sort of rich modeling
you know they may come up with different
representations we found like Java C's
representation of Java is different from
eclipses representation of Java clangs
is different from G significantly
different from GCC and what happens is
as soon as you start exposing a STS to
people you've made a contract with them
right they don't want to have to go you
don't you don't want to break their code
if you switch back in compilers which
we've done now twice at least twice we
switch from the Eclipse CDT indexer to
claim once clang started really kicking
ass and we switched from the Eclipse
Java indexer to Java C once it became
clear that that wasn't going to die and
anybody who was using our STS at that
point had to be rewritten so now we have
this kind of open question do we do we
do we come up with a language neutral
not a cross language canonical but you
know at least a compiler neutral
representation of not just that but the
types you know and for C++ you can get
into how you represent templates and
instantiations and specializations and
things like that it's tricky you know
and you can throw into the mix the build
system you can be using the same
compiler the same OS and using you know
you can be using ant or make or maven or
you know google's build system or
whatever your own build system and yeah
so this is a problem this is a problem
where we're now we're getting into views
of the graph that are kind of specific
to your project and so we want to
introduce the notion of a project space
in our graph so we can keep track of
what version of the compiler was at what
tool chain you know we as across
compiler at Google that can in theory
use GCC or clinic we use them both
actually so now we've got this basically
hypervisor of a compiler that we got to
talk to it'sit's quite complicated in
the answer is like for most things we
punt right now we don't we don't do a
very good job with that what we're
offering people as a service where they
can use grab they can make and run their
own version of grok on their own branch
using their own compilers and tools and
stuff and the index that's produced will
be all the things that are relevant for
their workspace which is a compromise
right it's not it's not perfect we'd
like to be able to you know generalize
across these things and come up with a
generic representation for what the
compiler Flags needed are the include
path or whatever but we get there may be
years but we understand that the
Bleck city of it and what we do is try
to make the maximum number of people
have you for the minimum effort that
answer your question yeah that was
interesting but it wasn't what I was
trying to ask okay suppose I've got a
specific compiler and I switched from
version you know 13 2006 the 13 dot 2.7
because it fixes the bug right yeah no
that's that's a that's so that's blood
problem it also the problem of compiler
versions fixing a bug which potentially
could change the representation of the
code that we've stored is is
generalizable across it actually happens
to most will terribly our build system
our ablaze representation changes you
know every few months and if we're
storing historical versions now we've
got fundamentally different semantic
representations across versions and it
makes query and card like you have this
question of okay from 13 to 7 to 13 to 5
there was this change in the way these
types were represented do we backfill
the data so that today's queries are as
if we had been compiling your code with
13 to 7 all along or do we tell clients
ok at this particular point in time your
query is going to get kind of weird
right this is that that closer to the
problem that you were asking about yeah
and you know this this is this is a
problem it's even a problem if the
compilers don't change but our data
model changes our representation becomes
more accurate or more precise or
whatever to defect to fix a bug and in
our representation and this is actually
a you know common problem with anybody
who's representing historical data at
Google right I mean even if it's mapped
to data right if you start collecting
different data you go back and retrofit
all the old historical maps if you're
keeping it around and boil by I don't
know do you know kind of love to know
the answer to this yes you're right you
have to keep track you have to model the
change itself that's ideally right and
yeah way so that's it that's the kind of
a meta modeling be able to recreate the
environment yep yeah so we have run into
this problem a few times the need to
sort of
we have we want to be so it's not
related to grok but we have a source
control system and people can Mike you
know check in code and and at a
particular point in time the code might
be good and then it's bad for a while as
people make changes and people may want
to go back and they want to get a fresh
build even just raqa purposes of that
particular time but unfortunately the
blaze that the build system our build
compiler as it were has changed
dramatically in the meantime so you have
to go back and you have to be able to
check out the compiler at that point in
time that was used yeah it's pretty
hairy I mean we have it it's hard when
you come to Google you know you it takes
a while to realize how much storage
space we have we have a lot of storage
space and you need to start thinking in
terms of storing everything for all time
even if it seems wasteful and we're
getting better about that and it was
only maybe after four years on this
project just over the holidays here that
I realized that we could probably store
our metadata for every file save that
everybody does all the time for all
history and I was like oh yeah I did the
math and I was like oh yeah that's a
tiny data set it seemed huge at first
right so yeah well we will we will model
those changes oh god yeah eventually
maybe but but that's hard that's hard is
when they finally get a board or a chip
thumb is they take the PC that they've
been doing the work on yes it's just
unplug it case they ever have to come
back to it yeah yeah so what we'll do is
we'll make a copy of our data center
every time okay so you got me that's a
hard one
the other questions any questions yes
how do you represent like macros your
graphic I mean what is matter
so if Lisp s4g macros and it has and it
also has Rieger macros which are like
lakhs also depends whether you're
talking about basically a super boss but
text macros you know there are they're a
little tricky we're working on them like
this quarter
what we want is really obvious okay we
want to be able to click on macro and
see it's one level expansion and
potentially it's n level expansions and
if there were any if there any macros
used within the macro expansion we wanna
be able to expand those and so on right
and then if there are identifiers that
are created or referenced inside of the
macro expansion or it's recursive
expansion then we want to be able to
index these things we have some clever
ideas that my team won't let me talk
about but I will I will I will
definitely lump that in the hard
question category it's a it's definitely
not an easy space I mean I think Canon
Brian Kernighan or maybe was Dennis
Ritchie said a couple of years ago that
yeah if they had to do it all over again
they probably would have left the C
processor she professes her out because
it just made such a mess for tool chains
forever after and it wouldn't have been
successful so it's tough right all right
well thank you you've been a lovely
audience thanks
you